georges bigot et puis il ya aussi le
sicob françoise kramer ça veut dire quoi
si comme le sea cove est un salon à la
fois professionnel et grand public il
sera inauguré tout à l'heure par
monsieur pierre mauroy le premier
ministre le sicop évidemment tout le
monde en parle la presse écrite il
consacre aujourd'hui des pages spéciales
fournies mais vous n'êtes peut être pas
très nombreux nous ne sommes peut-être
pas très nombreux effectivement à savoir
ce que c'est précisément qu'est ce qui
se cache derrière ce sigle le sicop
suivons le guide avec jacques violer le
moci cob qui hier signifiait salon
international de la communication et de
l'organisation de bureau c'est au fil
des années modifié aujourd'hui c'est le
salon de l'informatique de la
communication et de la bureautique
l'informatique envahi notre civilisation
ainsi tous ces mots que l'on ne comprend
pas toujours la bureautique la
télématique et la robotique
symbole de cette invasion le palais de
la défense qui accueille
traditionnellement le sicop est
aujourd'hui trop petit l'intérieur est
réservé aux grands aux matériels les
plus sophistiqués les plus chers pour
les professionnels les nouveaux venus la
bureautique sont installés à la boutique
sicob cette année c'est la micro
informatique pour tous et la thématique
la micro-informatique fait désormais
partie de la vie quotidienne
ici c'est le paradis de l'informatique
grand public les jeunes bien sûr avec
les innombrables jeux vidéo et la micro
informatique pour la famille à la maison
le développement des technologies a
permis de mettre au point de véritable
ordinateur personnel et personnalisé
mais les fabricants s'attaque surtout
aux petites et moyennes entreprises et
leur offre à travers une miniaturisation
et surtout une simplification
d'utilisation les possibilités infinies
de gestion et de comptabilité
aujourd'hui un micro ordinateur coûte
entre 3000 et 20 mille francs
certains fabricants offrent aux mêmes
sur le marché des matériels pas plus
gros qu'un livre et qui coûtent moins de
mille fois l'ordinateur individuel
domestique et familial est en train de
changer notre société
mais il devra se faire une place entre
la chaîne hi fi et le magnétoscope